durant dix jours la baleine à bosse a
offert aux montréal est un spectacle
aquatique de toute beauté
depuis elle semble avoir quitté la ville
elle a été vue pour la dernière fois
hier matin que la baleine était
possiblement un peu plus bas dans le
fleuve à la hauteur de pointe aux
trembles et depuis ce signalement là on
continue encore à chercher la baleine et
pour la localiser deux agents de pêcher
océans canada patrouille sur le fleuve
il espère que le cétacé soit en sécurité
un des principaux risques pour cet
animal l'a finalement c'est que il se
fasse soit frappé par un navire ou alors
qu'ils se s'engage dans une voie sans
issue et qui se retrouve finalement
bloquée la patrouille compte aussi sur
les signalements de riverains de marins
ou de pêcheurs
j'avais une bonne vingtaine d'années
fidèle au poste ce pêcheur de pointe aux
trembles n'a pas vu la baleine
l'espérait de la voir le nom pas de la
pêcher
c'est au château elle n'a pas de 10
mètres de long et d'une dizaine de
tonnes qui se retrouvaient à plus de 400
km de son habitat naturel
plusieurs questions sont en suspens mais
une chose est sûre cet animal de moins
de 3 ans n'avait jamais été répertoriés
par les scientifiques
cet animal c'est la première fois qu'on
voyait alors là ce qu'on espère tous en
ce moment c'est qu'elle a pris le chemin
du retour vers la maison puis on
continue pour le moment les patrouilles
sur lot de québec à montréal la baleine
à bosse a mis quatre jours en nageant à
contre-courant avec le courant du saint
laurent dans le dos le retour à la
maison pourrait lui prendre la moitié du
temps c'était vraiment coup de chance ce
qu'ils ont vu mais au fait des taux
courts et où elle est à cette question
nul n'a de réponse pour le moment ici à
ce mitraillage radio canada montréal